votre père vous aviez des problèmes avec
lui pas du tout mais ça c'est une
invention Xavier des problèmes avec
votre père
moi je vous dis que non
très heureux de vous accueillir vous
êtes ici ce soir dans le cadre de
l'opération tous amis avec Sarkozy il
nous recevrons des ami de gauche de
Nicolas Sarkozy la semaine dernière
Dominique Farrugia la semaine prochaine
Éric Besson j'apprends deux choses ce
soir je suis de gauche dessus pote avec
ça
du parti mais je les ai soutenus
beaucoup
vous êtes de quoi alors de gauche ou
droite
vous êtes toujours comédien en fait vous
avez pas compris si Crédit Lyonnais vous
avez fini les 400 millions d'euros c'est
pour soyez pas obligé de remonter sur
scène
en plus tout le blé que je gagne au
théâtre je l'ai donné à au Téléthon donc
voilà vous avez remarqué que depuis que
le Crédit Lyonnais vous a rendu votre
argent le système financier mondial se
casse la gueule quand même
est-ce que vous croyez qu'il y a une
relation de cause à effet évidemment
c'est la petite goutte d'eau quoi alors
Oscar le pitch c'est un PDG paranoïaque
et autoritaire qui affronte son homme
confiance tout en recherchant à lui
faire épouser sa fille chef d'entreprise
ringard assez compère aussi ringard pour
ça que c'est pas tellement un rôle de
composition
vous l'avez beaucoup réécrit ce beaucoup
on parle un peu de politique on parle un
peu justement des banques vous réglez
vos comptes avec des courses
quoi les planches d'abord je crois que
c'est l'envie de plaire c'est l'envie
d'être aimé c'est l'envie d'en avoir le
témoignage instantané et puis c'est
aussi jubilatoire moi en ce moment je
vois que les gens vraiment ils ont envie
de se marrer tu vois on a l'impression
qu'ils ont pas becqueté pendant 15 jours
et qui leur file attention on leur file
pas du cavernes et du foie gras c'est un
steak frites mais il se goinfre avec ça
alors évidemment vous êtes toujours été
acteur
non oh bah si vous êtes acteur dans la
vie non non dites chaque fois que je
prends la parole il y a des gens pour
penser que je fais un numéro de cirque
vous dites j'ai du mal à raconter des
mensonges on s'y attend tellement qu'on
est beaucoup plus en alerte j'ai beau
dire faut patieuse apparences
ça passe pas quoi moi pour qu'on me
donne le bon Dieu faut que
vous vous gérez comment cette suspicion
permanente dans si vous êtes l'objet
si vous saviez dites-moi je vous ai vu
quand même dans une audition à
l'Assemblée nationale en septembre
dernier vous étiez ému aux larmes quand
vous déclariez que votre nom a une
certaine époque était devenu une insulte
vous êtes vraiment vous aviez l'air ému
aux larmes vous jouiez la comédie là où
c'était sincère un jour un journaliste
en Bretagne écrit sur un type des trucs
assez assez dur quoi pas très sympa bon
bref le mec porte plainte en diffamation
le titre c'était monsieur machin le
tapis breton ah oui d'accord et il a été
condamné le journalisme à 50000 balles
d'amende pour avoir été traité de tapis
qui était une injure publique donc quand
on nom est prononcé et que ça génère une
injure publique qui condamne le
journaliste qui t'appelle comme ça ça
fait quand même quelque chose voilà
c'est vrai tapis quoi bon il y a les
pour et les contre non mais c'est vrai
Bernard je m'en fous vous êtes
extrêmement segmentant mais tout le
monde toi aussi vous quand même plus que
moi
non mais déjà quand vous étiez petit à
la maison vous étiez segmentant votre
père vous aviez des problèmes avec lui
pas du tout mais ça c'est une invention
Xavier des problèmes avec votre père
moi je vous dis que non
mais c'est pas grave mais attends si
c'était si c'était le cas je te dirai
j'ai des problèmes avec mon père avec
mon père c'est un homme ouvrier
communier après son boulot pour
progresser pour monter sa PME c'est
voilà c'est quelqu'un de rigoureux de
pas expansive de de voilà et vous à côté
vous étiez un peu rebelle un peu non
difficile pour vous parce que arrête
un peu mais c'est pas sur la même
longueur d'onde que lui et vous êtes
fait vous avez tenté de vous faire
psychanalyser à cause de ça je me suis
jamais fait un petit canaliser
de faire une petite
j'ai toujours été trop bien dans mes
pompes c'est pas grave de dire que mais
si c'était le cas sauf que c'est pas le
cas les moteurs essaient de
l'impressionner avec des voitures des
voyages et en fait il était beaucoup
plus rigoureux en plus vous aviez pas la
même morale que votre père disons
attends tu sais les familles de prolos
dans les années 50 quand j'ai 7 ans les
préoccupations c'est pas la psychanalyse
hein mon pote hein ça
la première fois que j'ai vu une salle
de bain dans ma vie j'avais 16 ans on
habitait à 4 dans 9 mètres 5 m² la salle
de bain c'était la même chose que
l'évier de la cuisine qui était la même
chose lui-même donc barquage c'est dans
ces cas-là tu as pas de problème de
psychanalyse hein tu vois et ton père
qui tu fais le con tu prends une baffe
point barre et si tu arrives de l'école
en disant le prof il m'a mis une tu en
prends une deuxième voilà d'accord donc
il y a pas non non votre mère elle vous
pardonnez tout elle vous a nourri au
sein jusqu'à 26 mois ça c'est vrai non
mais c'est rarissime nourrir un enfant
au sein jusqu'à 26 mois c'est énorme 24
24 mois et elle nous a fait des câlins
sur ses genoux jusqu'à l'âge de 17 ans
tu vois tu t'es fait comme moi faut que
tu me rajoutes un peu ton tapis faut que
tu rajoutes un peu quoi non mais ça me
fait mal il y a deux images de votre vie
qui montre les deux tapis à 14 ans
pendant les vacances vous faites vos
premiers pas de chanteurs dans un
dancing de Saint-Jean-de-Monts donc là
on sent l'ambition
on avait trois mois juin juillet je
bossais pour donner des ronds à mes
parents tout le temps et août j'allais
en vacances à Saint-Jean-de-Monts chez
des potes et là il y avait un casino et
je bossais comme chanteur d'orchestre
pour me payer mes vacances donc ça
remonte à loin l'histoire de Scar quand
même parce que dès l'âge de 14 ans il y
avait envie d'être sur scène quand même
quoi j'avais envie d'aller en vacances
gratos voici mon père avait des ronds
j'aurais jamais fait le short
il y a une autre date aussi très très
importante dans votre vie de 18 ans vous
êtes chez vous et il y a un démarcheur
qui passe pour vous vendre un téléviseur
et là vous avez une idée géniale vous
dites au gars mais non c'est pas du tout
comme ça qu'il faut faire et vous
trouvez une technique de vente
absolument géniale c'est-à-dire que vous
dites aux gens bonjour on fait une étude
sur la télé donc on va vous laisser un
téléviseur pendant une semaine puis
regarde comment les gens font avec cet
appareil et en général les gens la
gardaient après une fois qu'il l'avait
eu pendant 8 jours il l'avait c'est
assez fou ça le sens du marketing du
marchandising est sûrement une de mes
seules vraies qualités je sais faire ça
par cœur je rentre chez Look qui faisait
des fixations de ski et je leur fais
faire du vélo et c'est devenu la
première boîte de vélo dans le monde ça
c'est fait du marketing quoi et à
l'époque j'étais surcitaire j'attendais
d'être à l'armée et à l'armée vous avez
découvert finalement que tout le monde
était pareil si vous avez du bien
c'est mon tremplin ouais c'est le temps
là vous avez compris que d'un seul coup
j'étais pas plus l'inscrire c'est
important c'est important sous tous ces
membres de banlieues là qui aujourd'hui
pour se distinguer des autres font les
cons parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils peuvent
pas faire autrement si vous les mettez
dans des configurations on met égalité
les membres de riches et ceux-là ils
montreraient qu'ils sont dix fois plus
démerdes c'est pour ça que j'ai fait mes
écoles de formation pour les jeunes au
chômage je sais et c'est pour ça que
Chirac a eu tort de supprimer le service
militaire
en grande partie oui voilà je pense
qu'il a eu tort alors finalement
ce qu'on peut dire c'est contre le tapis
chanteur le tapis commerçant enfin tous
les tapis vous avez jamais vraiment
choisi on a l'impression quel tapis vous
étiez vraiment j'ai toujours été c'est
bizarre d'ailleurs parce que ma vie n'a
été faite que de suggestion des autres
j'ai jamais dit tiens je vais faire l'OM
ou tiens je vais faire une affaire où je
vais faire du théâtre où je vais faire
de la télé ça a toujours été quelqu'un
qui pensait qu'il me détient est-ce que
tu voudrais pas faire un truc et là
alors moi faut pas marquer moi je lui
propose un truc
de boule de flipper quoi complètement
c'est ça alors temps en temps j'ai fait
tilt hein alors la vie m'a donné
quelques quelques cordes et je tire
dessus et des fois et des fois l'accord
de casse et voilà et voilà alors Bernard
si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil probablement que de temps en
temps j'ai pas été j'ai pas été modeste
et j'ai été trop pressé et j'ai trop
parlé j'ai bon voilà ça va de soi qu'il
faut se servir de l'expérience pour pas
essayer de recommencer les mêmes choses
par exemple la prison est-ce que vous
pensez que ça a été une expérience au
bout du bout tu vas apporter quelque
chose complètement négatif
c'était de me mettre au trou c'était pas
parce que j'ai fait ça ou ça j'aurais
vécu à l'époque où le sac était encore
opérationnel on me retrouvait noyé dans
un étang de 25 cm comme boulot par
hasard et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu